place à présent et bien au match des
idées pour la troisième fois en amenant
le qu'ovide oblige donc l'exécutif à
mettre la france sous cloche les mesures
de freinage sont désormais nationale ce
qui signifie une restriction des
libertés publiques et individuelles pour
tous les français ces mesures sont-elles
justifiées qu'elle garde fous mettre en
place face à ces sacrifices de liberté
qui sont demandés à nos compatriotes
faut-il craindre un état d'urgence
permanent
c'est le premier thème le chômage des
idées après le point sur la situation et
flora sauvage couvre-feu limitations de
déplacements à plus de dix kilomètres de
son domicile
interdiction de se rassembler à plus de
six personnes depuis un an les
restrictions se multiplient pour freiner
l'épidémie de kevin 19 autant
d'atteintes aux libertés individuelles
détaillé cet après midi par jean castex
au sénat
la consommation d'alcool dans l'espace
public sera interdite sur arrêté
préfectoral est en lien étroit avec les
maires l'accès à certains sites propices
à des rassemblements en extérieur comme
les cas berges place pour être interdits
en fonction des circonstances locales à
partir de samedi
les 46 millions de français qui
n'étaient pas concernés par les mesures
de confinement vont voir leur liberté de
déplacement réduite garant des libertés
publiques
le sénat s'inquiète des conséquences de
ces mesures les gens vont finir par
s'habituer et ne plus voir passer la
démocratie sous leurs yeux
on a plus de l'union de base sortiront
peut pas déplacer une
certaines limites c'est pas et puis on
nous a mis dans une bulle qui a été
inefficace au sein de la majorité
sénatoriale de droite on ne cache pas
son agacement face à la méthode employée
par le gouvernement fait une restriction
aux libertés incontestablement
mais depuis le début de cette crise
c'est le principe même de la politique
qui est conduite
nous avions dit encadrent confinement et
c'est bien 1re confinement même si le
mot n'est pas prononcé
il faut une loi le gouvernement a refusé
cette loi ces nouvelles mesures
coûteront 11 milliards d'euros de plus
par mois au budget de l'état selon bercy
si l'on prend en compte la fermeture des
commerces et la mise au chômage partiel
des parents contraints de garder leurs
enfants à la maison
reste à savoir si ces restrictions
seront respectés par la population déjà
durement éprouvée depuis un an est avec
nous pour ce match des idées paul cassia
bonjour vous êtes professeur de droit
public à l'université paris 1 panthéon
sorbonne et je cite l'un de vos livres
la république en miettes aux éditions
libre et solidaire avec nous également
romain duperey bonjour vous êtes avocat
au barreau de paris à new york et
président des juristes en marche
on va parler tout d'abord de la question
des libertés publiques
une nouvelle fois les libertés sont
atteintes à la liberté d'aller et venir
notamment avec la limitation des
déplacements 2 à 10 km heure les
interdictions de rassemblements à plus
de six personnes qui seront bien plus
sévèrement réprimée d'ailleurs jean
castex a été assez clair là dessus
ces atteintes aux libertés sont elles
justifiées par la situation sanitaire
paul cassia les goûters j'aurais bien
voulu pouvoir répondre à votre question
mais je n'en sais rien et je suis au
regret de constater que personne n'en
sait rien nous sommes en état d'urgence
sanitaire depuis le 17 octobre 2020 nous
sommes sous couvre feu depuis le 16
janvier 2021 à 18 heures est désormais à
19 heures et il n'y a eu aucune
évaluation des mesures restrictives de
liberté qui ont été prises depuis le 17
octobre 2020 et en particulier de
efficacité du couvre-feu alors on nous
dit qu'il est efficace mais il n'y a
aucune étude qui le démontrent donc ce
que nous avons de manière certaine
ce sont des restrictions de liberté à la
fois au plan national et qui viennent
s'ajouter auxquels viennent s'ajouter
des restrictions aux libertés au plan
local
ça c'est acquis en revanche ce que nous
ne savons pas c'est si ces restrictions
aux libertés ont une incidence sanitaire
qui les justifient qui est fait qu'elle
peut être à la fois nécessaire et
strictement proportionnées donc je ne
suis donc dans la capacité de savoir si
les restrictions aux libertés sont à la
fois nécessaire et strictement
proportionnées
romain d'hyper et en même temps on a
aussi vu que des images de rassemblement
de fête sauvage par exemple sur les
quais de saône par exemple à lyon qui
démontre aussi et bien que on a il ya
quand même cette tentation d'aller bien
à l'encontre des des gestes barrières
donc à ce que pour vous il faut ces
restrictions ces règles sur les qui
permettent aussi et bien aux forces de
l'ordre de verbaliser des règles il en
faut oui bien sûr on serait sorti
totalement la pandémie on se poserait
pas la question je pense que ces
contraintes l'exécutif les adoptés à
reculons on a bien vu qu'il y avait
aucun enthousiasme à venir poser ses
contraintes aux français en ont vendu
faisait le procès il ya deux mois de ne
l'avoir pas fait un rappelons nous on
nous a dit merkel risque prenez vous à
ne pas mettre plus de contraintes sur
nos concitoyens à les laisser libres
d'aller et venir dans beaucoup de
limites toute la journée sous réserve du
couvre-feu
donc bon le
le gouvernement joue un rôle
d'équilibriste qui est très difficile
que personne en tout cas je ne serais
pas le jouer à sa place pour essayer de
concilier ces contraintes sanitaires
avec et les libertés fondamentales qui
sont nombreuses et qui sont fortement
attendre depuis très longtemps et avec
aussi d'autres considérations
économiques et sociales donc c'est une
équation à de très nombreux paramètres
et c'est vrai que bon le président a
fait un acte de contrition un peu en
disant qu'il n'avait sans doute pas été
parfait c'est moi évidemment on ne peut
qu aux conquois vers ça mais des mesures
sont essentielles tant que la pandémie
n'est pas éradiquée oui elle paul cassia
effectivement on sent qu'il maniait
macron cherche une forme d' équilibre
par exemple les restrictions de liberté
elles sont étendues mais dans le même
temps c'est la fin des attestations hier
mais emmanuel macron à d'ailleurs
déclaré je le cite certains militait
pour le retour de l'attestation nous
n'avons pas retenu cette option
l'irresponsabilité de quelques-uns ne
doit pas ruiner les efforts de tous les
contrôles seront renforcés sur la voie
publique pour limiter les rassemblements
nous faisons le choix de la confiance de
la responsabilité et de la respiration
est ce que ça vous rassure autres on est
davantage sur un principe de
responsabilité même si une partie du
discours est aussi assez culpabilisant
écoutez franchement là je sais ces
propos ne me conviennent pas du tout on
ne peut pas dire nous faisons le choix
de leurs responsabilités et en même
temps indiqué que les contrôles
policiers vont être renforcés sais c'est
pas possible il ya un contrat dit que la
discordance dans le discours alors quand
le président de la république indique
que nombreux sont ceux qui souhaitaient
le maintien de l'attestation sa
généralisation moi je n'ai rencontré
personne peut être que romain et n'est
pas de cet avis mais je n'ai rencontré
personne qui manifestaient pour bébé
pour avoir une attestation
je voudrais simplement indiqué que le
président a dit quelque chose
d'absolument inexactes l'attestation
n'est pas obligatoire le décret du 29
octobre 2020 ne la prévoit pas il est
indiqué par le premier ministre jean
castex tu que nous devons disposer d'un
document justifiant de nos déplacements
ces documents peuvent être notre
président entités peuvent être une
une attestation de travail peuvent être
un certificat de l'employeur ce qu'on
voit danser d'ailleurs aucun média mais
la prestation en elle même n'est pas
obligatoire c'est un formulaire qui
n'est pas obligatoire il est facultatif
un formulaire facultatif romain du père
aimé qu'on s'est bien imposé vous étiez
vous militez pour le retour de
l'attestation non effectivement je pense
pas qu'on eut de nombreux militants pro
attestation ça je pense qu'on peut on
peut être d'accord là-dessus mentir
après effectivement je pense qu'il a
assez utile quand même d'expliquer de
pouvoir expliquer pourquoi on passe d'un
territoire à l'autre dans un moment où
il faut effectivement essayé de limiter
la progression du virus donc
l'attestation a effectivement n'est pas
une obligation
après c'est vrai qu'il faut en faire
appel à la responsabilité collective si
vous voulez qui est des petits écarts à
droite à gauche dans un système
extrêmement complexe que parfois on ne
comprend pas tout c'est une chose qui
est volontairement des rassemblements
massifs de gens qui ne respectent aucune
règle c'en est une autre et là
effectivement il faut savoir faire
preuve d'autorité parce qu'ils se
mettent en danger eux si ce n'était que
la limite la liberté devrait primer un
ils feront à et prennent des risques
qu'ils veulent tant que ça ne concerne
qu'eux mais à partir du moment où ça met
en danger des personnes vulnérables sur
le plan de la santé
à ce moment là il faut savoir sévir ce
d'autant plus qu'aujourd'hui encore
combien de nos concitoyens sont morts de
ce virus 200 250 300 c'est un virus qui
a fait cent mille morts en un an et on
ne les voit jamais assez vrai quand on
parle beaucoup plus des gens qui sont en
train de faire la fête que des gens ils
sont en train de mourir mais il y en a
c'est vrai qu'on est pas pour qu'on ne
les voit jamais donc c'est vrai qu'il
faut savoir s'en soucie aussi pour qu'il
y en ait moins le temps qu'on en sorte
et il faut encore quelques semaines
voire quelques mois
oui alors il ya siam nous avons un une
forme de confinement ou pseudo
confinement au quasi confinement qui est
particulièrement sévère en europe et
avec ce paradoxe qui nous incite à être
soi même responsable tout en policier
visant l'état d'urgence sanitaire
donc c'est un double discours un petit
peu qu'équipier gênant le président de
la république a indiqué que en allemagne
le confinement durée depuis quatre mois
ça aussi c'est complètement inexacte
c'est une deuxième
attitude qui a été dit hier soir par le
président de la république il n'y a pas
de confinement en allemagne comme on en
connaît chez nous il ya des mesures de
restriction de direction c'est pas la
même chose que j'aime bien évidemment
que non il n'y a pas de couvre-feu
en particulier il n'y a pas d' amende de
135 euros il n'y a pas d'obligation de
présenter un document et pourtant le
taux d'incidence est trois fois
inférieure à celle où le nombre de morts
est inférieur les services de
réalisation ne sont pas débordés en même
temps les libertés sont mieux préservés
donc moi je voudrais juste que quelqu'un
le premier ministre un ministre peut
être romain me démontre que les mesures
restrictives de liberté qui sont prises
au moins depuis janvier 2021 ne sont pas
contre productive ne sont pas elle même
un facteur de propagation du virus
je vous demande juste parce que ça
puisse être établi et j'ai à 7h à ce
jour je n'ai pas ici de documents qui me
permettent d'affirmer que ces mesures ne
sont pas elle même contre-productive
dans ce contexte a aussi l'un des sujets
c'est que ces restrictions pas sans
aucune loi supplémentaire ce qui
préoccupe certains parlementaires
regardez par exemple ce que tweet
philippe barre l'ex président de la
commission des lois dans quelle autre
démocratie le gouvernement pourrait-il
confiné sa population fermer ses écoles
en se contentant d'une intervention du
président à la télévision suivi d'une
simple déclaration gouvernementale
devant le parlement sans loi romain du
père est bon ça rejoint aussi tout le
contexte aujourd'hui on voit que les
parlementaires ont le sentiment qu'on
leur passe haut au dessus et qui n'ont
absolument pas leur mot à dire mais
est-ce que effectivement il n'ya pas un
problème démocratique à ce que tous
puissent passer juste après une
allocation une allocution et un discours
du premier ministre
si vous voulez philippe basse et c'est
un opposant très virulent gouvernement
c'est un peu une boîte à claques qu'on
ouvre et qui critique de toute façon
quoi qui soit mais sur le fond fini pour
le foot
mais chaque coin de rue dans ce plateau
il ya une une citation de philippe bas
qui critique au vitriol ce qu'avait fait
le gouvernement c'est alicia si lucratif
que le gouvernement ait décidé de ne pas
confiné où le confiner la dernière fois
c'était une petite citation de philippe
bas qui se peignaient qu'on ne
sollicitait pas assez le sénat alors
qu'il expliquait avoir voté mais
peut-être plus d'une dizaine de fois sur
ces questions d'urgence sanitaire il y à
une loi d'urgence sanitaire qui est en
vigueur à l'heure actuelle qui autorise
le gouvernement à faire ce qu'il a fait
c'est là aussi sans vigueur le 1er juin
il ya eu un débat cet après midi en
présence du premier ministre qui est
quand même venu s'expliquer des heures
durant devant les sénateurs et écouté
toutes les critiques qu'ils avaient à
formuler et s'en nourrir donc on veut
pas dire que le sénat est piétiné en
dépit de l'exigence d'efficacité
évidente qu'il ya dans le cadre de cette
situation effectivement on est dans un
état d'urgence jusqu'au 1er juin c'est
ce qui permet et au gouvernement
aujourd'hui absolument il n'y a pas
besoin d'aller devant le parlement s'est
pas tué ce n'est pas une nécessité
le problème philippe bas le poète il y à
bien un problème mais il n'est pas
démocratique
il est d'ordre ontologique en quelque
sorte il est supérieur
est ce que un gouvernement peut confiner
toute une population y compris pour des
impératifs sanitaires
est ce qu'il est possible de fermer
toutes les écoles y compris par exemple
dans la creuse ou à paris pour des pour
des témoins des motifs sanitaires
donc il ya là une question d'ordre
philosophique qui se pose le problème
c'est que nous avons enfin le parlement
a donné les pleins pouvoirs au
gouvernement il a carte blanche
dès lors que son action tente à assurer
notre sécurité sanitaire y peut tout
faire
tout absolument tout faire nous confiner
nous confiner admis nous confine à akkar
fermer les écoles et lycées
vers interdire l'alcool sur la voie
publique donc il n'y a aucune limite en
réalité à ce que le gouvernement peut
faire et c'est vraiment problématique
c'est extrêmement problématique philippe
bas a raison de le souligner mais le
problème c'est que c'est le parlement
qui l'a autorisé cet excès de pouvoir
permanent qui a été restreint dans le
temps par l'action du sénat ce que le
gouvernement de demander encore un état
d'urgence davantage prolonger dans le
temps on voit que c'est vraiment une
situation qui vous qui vous émeut on
voit les oppositions qui s'émeuvent de
cette situation nous sommes également en
liaison avec émile le clark et directeur
d'études chez oddo que ça vous avez fait
un sondage autour et bien de 2,2 de la
caille un qu'ont les français de ces
mesures et pour le coup les français ils
y sont plutôt favorables
oui effectivement et français approuve
les mesures annoncées il ya soir par
emmanuel macron que ce soit la fermeture
des écoles
l'interdiction des déplacements
interrégions toutes les mesures sont
sont approuvés et ça c'est pas nouveau
dans l'opinion et français approuvent
systématiquement dès lors que les
piquets qui les dynamiques sont élevés
les français approuvent les mesures
annoncées par le par le gouvernement
être qu'ils approuvent mois que
auparavant lors des précédents sondages
que vous aviez pu faire lors de
précédents confinement non pas
particulièrement alors jouer le chiffre
s'afficher sur sur votre écran
effectivement on parle aussi peut-être
alors mais mes cd niveau effectivement
de d'approbation qui sont élevés tout
simplement parce que les français
placent la santé avant
leur quotidien d'une certaine manière
c'est important pour eux qu'on protège
et donc qui est con qu'on fasse baisser
la courbe épidémique le carton avait un
petit peu anticipé sur le deuxième thème
on va passer au deuxième thème de ce
match des idées les élections
départementales et régionales pourront
elles se tenir au mois de juin
on l'a entendu un seul scénario
privilégié par jean castex qui a bien
insisté tout à l'heure seules des
raisons sanitaires impérieuse pourrait
justifier un nouveau report romandie
terrer pour vous était justifiée des
journées des élections raison du
contexte sanitaire c'est aussi ajourné
la démocratie la mettre en parenthèse ça
commence à devenir compliqué quand ça
fait un an de pandémie le principe se
devait de respecter les règles les
règles c'est que ces élections elles
devaient avoir lieu ce mois-ci x a pas
été le cas
donc elles ont déjà été reporté une fois
donc c'est vrai que la question se pose
est est-ce qu'il faut impérativement les
reporter à nouveau il ya quand même des
arguments pour et contre
c'est pour ça que le conseil
scientifique a été sollicité il a été
très prudent malgré tout lui la liaison
a tranché il me sens moi la lecture du
rapport qui était plutôt partisans d'un
report jusqu'au mois de septembre qui
ont été assez sage en dix ans il y aura
plus de gens vaccinés beaucoup plus de
gens vaccinés en septembre donc ça vaut
peut-être le coup de passer l'été et
d'attendre le gouvernement est aussi
sensible aux arguments très forts de
l'autre côté c'est ça la difficulté de
cette crise c'est qu'il ya souvent des
arguments très forts des deux côtés qui
s'affrontent
il faut une respiration démocratique à
un moment c'est important ça fait
longtemps que les français n'ont pas
voté
il faut qu'ils puissent le faire le
rapport du conseil scientifique ya
beaucoup d'exemples qui sont données sur
ce qui pourrait être fait est-ce qu'on
pouvait pas voter sur deux jours plutôt
que sur un jour comme l'a fait de
manière ancestrale fois essayé ou en
soient moins nombreux les pays bas ont
fait un vote sur trois jours en
extérieur on pouvait même vous êtes sur
son vélo parce que l'on pouvait pas
envisager ce genre de choses là leur
apparemment on peut pas envisager des
votes électroniques ou par
correspondance pour ces élections là non
trop tard et a d'ailleurs une
proposition l'addition a été refusée en
60 mais c'est un peu dommage pas le cas
sia bon alors je ne sais pas s'il faut
gouverner par sondage ou pas mais si
c'est le cas je constate chez j'ai lu
que 71% des français
le report des ralentis c'est le cas donc
s'il faut gouverner par sondage à ce
moment la tendance est plutôt pour le
report des élections déjà gouverné
nécessairement parce ont été reportés
l'avis du conseil scientifique et pour
une fois moi je les lis tout c'est un
peu équilibré c'est à dire qu'il n'est
pas sanità au centre et comme l'été tous
les précédents
il est mesuré c'est à dire que le
conseil scientifique dit moi j'ai des
compétences sanitaires et le reste ne me
regarde pas c'est à dire que c'est un
avis qui a été rendu n'est pas une pré
décision donc c'est appréciable
et c'est après cet avis renvoie aux
autorités politiques le soin de faire un
choix et ça aussi c'est très appréciable
et bienvenue et c'est désormais au
parlement au gouvernement de décider si
les élections pourront se tenir en juin
et ce serait bien que ce soit ce choix
soit fait très rapidement
il faut distinguer l'organisation de la
campagne du scrutin lui-même le monde y
va trés le scrutin on l'a vu lors des
élections de l'année passée des
municipales ne pose pas de difficulté en
termes sanitaires on peut parfaitement
s'organiser pour que les règles
sanitaires soient respectés il ya plus
de monde dans les boulangeries et dans
les supermarchés que dans les bureaux de
vote c'est évident les dès dimanche pour
l'organisation des campagnes on a tout
réglé à la halle à la mesure du coc vide
les enseignements à l'université le
télétravail
les ventes en un click and collect on
peut faire la même chose pour les
élections donc je crois qu'il est urgent
que le président la république le
gouvernement et le parlement nous dise
si ces élections vont se tenir ou pas en
juin l art en ont déjà commencé la
campagne
ils n'ont pas attendu alors il faut
entendre il ya la campagne officielle et
puis la campagne médiatique qui a déjà
commencé dans beaucoup de régions quand
même et vous le disais pas le cas ça
beaucoup de français en tout cas sont
prêts à ce report un emile leclerc votre
sondage qui a été fait avant les
annonces d'hier montre que les français
approuvent un report des régionales pour
raisons sanitaires
on peut imaginer qu'avec les annonces
d'hier ils vont être encore renforcé
dans ses convictions
alors ça
demandez c'est déjà un niveau élevé
effectivement quand on les interroger la
semaine dernière avant les annonces déjà
dans un contexte épidémique élevé 71%
des français nous disent eh bah oui
j'approuverai un report c'était déjà car
on les avait déjà interrogé sur ce sujet
en octobre dernier pour un report sur
les élections qui devaient se tenir en
mars et c'était un niveau équivalent en
fait les français placent la règle de la
santé d'abord
aujourd'hui et c'est vrai qu'ils sont
encore très éloignées aux élections
régionales et départementales
c'est pas une élection présidentielle
dans leur dans leur esprit donc il en
parle assez peu c'est quelque chose qui
n'est pas très présent dans l'opinion
publique et donc ça particulièrement et
c'est compréhensible et c'est normal le
microcosme politique mais quand on
regarde dans l'opinion
pour l'instant c'est vraiment un non
sujet et donc on peut imaginer que si
les élections étaient maintenues au mois
de juin et il faudrait craindre une
baisse de la participation selon vous si
on part du principe que déjà ça les
intéresse pas beaucoup et même
paradoxalement non puisqu'on les
interroger aussi dans ce sondage sur
leur intention de participer alors c'est
toujours assez délicat on ne mesurait
intentions on a des indicateurs qui nous
montrent qu'en fait il ya un niveau de
participation qu'on évalue à 50 9% qui
peut largement évolué et qui évoluera
probablement si on est dans un contexte
sanitaire avec une avec des
contaminations qui sont toujours très
élevés là ça pourrait être plus
problématique
mais aujourd'hui lorsqu'on les interroge
les français nous disent bah oui j'ai
envie d'aller voter à ces élections
c'est assez paradoxal
ils sont d'accord pour qu'on les reporte
mais il nous dit j'ai envie d'aller
voter et c'est plus problématique pour
les partis de gouvernement pour plus en
plus on est à l'extrême en plus ces
questions problématiques de ce report
parce qu'il ya le sentiment aussi qu'on
peut voler la démocratie donc c'est plus
important chez les sympathisants la
france est soumise ou leur assemblée
nationale par exemple
merci m il est clair pour que les rage
parce qu'à cias que du point de vue du
droit
il ya une deadline pour ces élections à
skagerrak qui font qu'elles peuvent pas
se tenir par donc trop près de la
présidentielle ou est-ce que tout est
ouvert
non il y à des règles qui s'imposent le
conseil constitutionnel les a évoqué
l'année passée à propos du report des
régimes des élections municipales du
second tour des élections municipales il
peut y avoir un report pourvu que pour
le second tour il ne soit pas trop
éloigné du premier et il y a des règles
constitutionnelles qui s'impose celle de
la sincérité du scrutin et celle aussi
de la périodicité du scrutin en ce sens
que bon on peut pas reporter de manière
trop systématique des élections y
compris locales
or l'année prochaine il y à des
élections nationales qui s'annonce et on
voit mal qui lie à un cumul comme ça de
l'élection locale et nationale paru en
normalement content qu'il y ait un
report il faut quand même que des
principes de nécessité et de
proportionnalité souaqi l'avis du
conseil scientifique ne démontre pas que
la situation sanitaire
aujourd'hui et peut être en juin
imposerait à toute force un report des
élections qui devraient se tenir en juin
la romandie père est donc en tout cas ça
montre que l'hypothèse que souhaité
certains à la république en marge d'un
report après l'élection présidentielle
c'est extrêmement compliqué si on en
croit parce que la ville pourra voir le
conseil constitutionnel oui ça serait
vraiment une situation extrême ce qui
était envisagé par le conseil
scientifique est ce qu'on reporte tout
même à l'automne 2000 22,2 c'est qu'on
nous avons
on a beaucoup fait au procès la
république en marche de vouloir reporter
cette élection parce qu'elle ne semblait
pas très bien engagée c'est pour ça que
ce serait d'autant plus justifiée
qu'elle se tienne et que je suis plutôt
rassuré que le premier ministre ne
tiennent pas compte de ces hommages
d'avoir à faire face à ce type de procès
d'actes mans s'impose pas un mouvement
politique
il va aller aux élections c'est jamais
facile il est en péril en gagne mais en
tout cas on ne fera pas faire ce procès
d'intention de vouloir les éviter allez
pour terminer on va continuer à parler
d'élections mais pas en lien avec le co
vide on va revenir sur le sort réservé
par la droite sénatoriale aux projets de
lois confortant le respect des principes
de la république
on va parler de l'interdiction des
listes communautaire l'une des mesures
votées par la majorité sénatoriale il a
écouté le président est bien du groupe
et l'air au sénat à bruno retailleau le
parti que je visais le parti égalité
justice qui semble être
suivant un certain nombre de
spécialistes une officine de la cap et
et bien il avait présenté aux cantonales
dans le bas rhin des candidats il a
ensuite présenté en 2017 dans plus de 50
circonscriptions pourquoi parce que
c'était pour atteindre les financements
publics
c'était tout voilà et on s'est très très
bien les difficultés que ça pose est ce
que madame la ministre
lorsque vous fermez la mosquée de pantin
il ya des problèmes c'est compliqué il a
fallu d'ailleurs un effort du juge
vous le savez très bien et du réseau
nous proposer une formulation
législatives pour que la fermeture des
cultes soit plus opérationnel eh bien
nous voulons proposer là aussi un
certain nombre d'outils pour qu' on
puisse mettre fin à ses menées
communautariste et réponse de la
ministre présente dans l'hémicycle et
marlène schiappa c'est une atteinte aux
libertés de candidature d'opinion
d'expression et pour vous paul cassia
écoutez là vraiment cette loi sur le
séparatisme contre le séparatisme
confortant les principes république en
même temps que les détricote d'une
manière absolument inouïe je crois que
les pères fondateurs de la troisième
république doivent se retourner dans
leur tombe
ce que fait cette loi à la liberté
d'association à la laïcité à la liberté
d'enseigner et est incroyable c'est elle
a parlé du texte initial vous parler du
sort qui est en train d'être
hermia la droite a tenu exactement
inverse à son intitulé est le problème
de cette loi c'est ce qui ressort aussi
de ce que vient de dire le sénateur
retailleau
il dépose un amendement en pointant un
mouvement et cet amendement concernera
l'intégralité des évictions
l'intégralité des listes c'est c'est le
problème de cette loi qui part qui
utilise un peu infâme filets maillants
dérivants législatif pour essayer
d'attraper des petits bancs de poissons
donc quand il y a des petits problèmes
on essaye de les régler autrement que
par des législations qui sont
extrêmement envahissantes telles que
celles qui ce qui se présente
quant à l'argument qui est invoquée qui
est de rechercher des financements
publics
donc je crois pas que ce soit contraire
à quelques principes que ce soit à
supposer que ce soit avéré romain de
peiresc effectivement on a pris un filet
trop large dans ce texte alors que on
l'a entendu un moult fois dans l'exposé
des motifs il s'agit de lutter contre
l'islamisme radical est par exemple on a
vu et bien certain nombre d'églises
estimé et bien qu'elle allait être
entachée que ça va être un vrai problème
pour la liberté de culte c'est peut-être
pas forcément ce qui était visé alors
est ce que on a pris un filet trop l'ars
qui ont je pense qu'elle ait des forces
centrifuges qui sont alain envers notre
pays à l'origine du projet de loi il ya
des forces centrifuges très très forte
alors dans notre pays il faut pas être
naïf à l'égard de sang il faut lutter
avec la même énergie pour ramener tous
les français dans le même creuset un qui
est assez large pour accueillir tout le
monde
mais il faut reconstituer ce creux se
creuser le texte de loi qui est passé à
l'assemblée nationale il avait ses
défauts mais il était quand même
beaucoup plus pointu que tous les
amendements qui apporte sénat
franchement notamment se disent
communautaire
la narration du mois
moi l'allemagne vise le sénat a agi des
totems qui viennent exactement à
l'encontre de l'objet de ce texte qui au
contraire de recréer de la fraternité
entre les français quelle que soit leur
confession et là c'est un exemple assez
frappant c'est que là on touche quand
même une liberté qui est importante
alors qui est au cas par cas des listes
problématique d'accord on va pas faire
une loi pour interdire certains partis
combien de partis sont interdits en
france
donc c'est pas si vous voulez en
interdisant qu'on va régler ce problème
et qu'on va renforcer les principes
républicains
c'est pour ça qu'il faut se limiter sur
quelques sujets qui sont pas si nombreux
finalement effectivement la manière et
de la matière est très fragile parce
qu'on touche à l'organisation
d'associations de culte etc et il faut
le faire de manière ciblée et c'est vrai
qu'il ya un certain équilibre encore une
fois c'est un chemin de crête qui est
très étroit on risque toujours de mettre
le pied à côté mais c'est pas pour ça
qu'il faut pas le suivre et à
l'assemblée il y avait un certain
équilibre qui est là le sénat en train
de jouer on voit bien que au bureau
bruno retailleau envoie un message aux
électeurs éventuelle de valérie pécresse
qui elle-même bon donc ça il a appris
une cuisine interne aux républicains
mais en tout cas c'est très mauvais
signe les débats qui ont eu lieu hier au
ces normes
paul cassia ce que dira aux mains du
père et je le partage absolument
le problème c'est que ça vaut pour
l'ensemble des dispositions de cette loi
y compris pour celles qui ont été
adoptées à l'assemblée nationale je
prends l'exemple de l'instruction
extrait l'instruction à domicile qui a
été voilà que le président de la
république souhaitait voir interdire ce
était inconstitutionnelle alors le
gouvernement a adopté un mécanisme
différent c'est un mécanisme qui est
désormais déclaratif il faut une
autorisation du recteur il faudrait une
autorisation de recteur pour pouvoir
faire une instruction à domicile très
bien mais combien d'élèves
combien de familles sont concernés par
un éventuel séparatisme religieux en
organisant cette instruction à domicile
on ne le sait pas on a demandé au
gouvernement il a été demandé aux
gouvernements qu'ils produisent des
chiffres il n'y en a pas eu il y aurait
50 mille élèves qui seraient instruit à
domicile mais on ne sait pas sur ces 50
milles
la proportion de ceux d'entre eux qui
recevraient une éducation qui seraient
éventuellement contraire aux principes
de la république
c'est d'autant mieux contrôler cet
instant le contrôle le contrôle tout le
monde est pour
mais le contrôle ne suppose pas comme ça
a été voté à l'assemblée nationale et
comme c'était préconisées par le
gouvernement
un mécanisme déclaratif qui est
contraire au principe de liberté
d'enseignement qu'il était prévu par par
la loi de 1881 min 30 à l'assemblée
c'est un principe d'autorisation
préalable alors même que maintenant mais
le sénat préconise un principe de
déclaration a fait effectivement sur ce
point précis le sénat s'est montré sage
on s'est quand même son rôle est
justement à proposer un quelque chose
d'intermédiaire et finalement ça c'est
peut-être mieux mais c'est le contre
exemple de tout ce qu'a fait le sénat
hier quand même là c'est quelque chose
de encore une fois où il a su mettre un
bémol à ces utile et effectivement ça
nous permettra peut-être de savoir si
toutes les déclarations viennent d'une
même zone géographique qui par ailleurs
est connue pourrait défavoriser au temps
où il y en ait tendance radicale là au
moins on aura une information utile pour
dire écoutez non là on arrête de faire
de l'enseignement à la maison tout on va
à l'école de la république
donc voilà donc ça c'est en
contre-exemple effectivement moi je suis
pour qu'on passe à un système de
déclaration et d'autorisation pour le
reste il faut que le sénat arrêt de
faire des situations politiques et
reviennent à un débat est vraiment
fondamental sur ce clou est ce que ce
texte
au final pour vous je suis désolé jour
un énorme sujet mais est ce qui porte
vraiment atteinte ou pas à la loi de
1905 une loi qui télénantes ont
normalement sans c'est plutôt rénové oui
je crois qu'il porte atteinte à tous les
principes là tous les principes de la
loi des lois de grandes la troisième
république la loi de 1901 à la loi de
1905 la loi de 1881 sur la liberté de
l'enseignement et le conseil
constitutionnel aura
son mot à dire sur ce sujet je pense
qu'on a perdu deux fêtes de vue le fait
qu'en 1905 la loi de 1905 a été
complètement disruptive et tout le monde
vous à des critiques qu'elle jetait
l'opprobre sur les catholiques et que
c'était pas comme ça qu'on allait faire
une communauté nationale et maintenant
c'est le totem de cette communauté
donc c'est pour ça que je pense qu'il
faut avoir le courage d'aller au fond de
ce sujet eh bien merci beaucoup à tous
les deux d'avoir participé à ce match
des idées fin de cette émission demain à
7h30 vous avez rendez vous avec ariane
mancini et bonjour chez vous elle
recevra notamment nicolas dupont aignan
député de l'essonne et président de
debout la france
excellente soirée sur public sénat